même si on a eu un bel avant goût tout à
l'heure avec le karting en tout cas
nickel et minero est revenu en plateau
pour m'accompagner dans cette partie
sport et on disait tout à l'heure on va
parler de rugby avec le plaisir Rugby
Club l'équipe senior a été éliminé en
16ème de finale de Fédérale 2 une saison
exceptionnelle pour le club nous disait
tout à l'heure Thierry l'amandé qui est
le président du club et vous avez été
rejoint par Guillaume Raynaud qui est
directeur sportif bonjour allô bonsoir
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
Thierry lamendez sur le qualification
qualificatif de tout à l'heure et une
saison exceptionnelle une très bonne
saison exceptionnelle à tous niveaux que
ce soit sur la structure du club et les
projets engagés et puis sur les
résultats sportifs tout à fait de
d'avoir perdu en 16e de finale c'est pas
un échec selon vous tirer l'amendée non
c'est un apprentissage donc je pense
qu'il faut faire mieux l'année prochaine
nickel oui ben on a de la pub où je suis
tout au long de la saison on a vu que
l'équipe a vraiment brillé cette saison
l'équipe a peut-être raté le coche en
terminant pas deuxième peut-être vous
avez le sentiment là ou pas Guillaume il
y a eu des droits de la poule
de la saison ça vous aurez peut-être
permis d'aller un peu plus loin du coup
en tout cas de effectivement de garder
cette seconde place au détriment de
Courbevoie après encore une fois c'est
un groupe qui progresse l'année en année
donc l'expérience elle est prise et
c'est surtout préparé maintenant l'année
prochaine peut-être avec des objectifs
un peu et c'est un groupe que vous
voulez garder vous allez garder
conserver tout le monde c'est l'objectif
c'est mieux que vous je crois que c'est
la base du club c'est le l'ambiance du
club aussi donc
ça fonctionne je vois pas pourquoi
les gens sont bien ok
c'est de garder l'effectif actuel déjà
c'est un premier pas je suis bien enclin
de roman que je veux donc c'est le ski
normalement est fait alors pour préparer
justement la saison prochaine alors pas
forcément au niveau de l'équipe senior
mais dans tout le plaisir Rugby Club
dans sa globalité vous avez organisé une
journée de détection récemment chez les
jeunes quel était l'objectif de cette
journée promouvoir le CEL donc cel qui a
été labellisé il y a deux mois de ça par
la Fédération française de rugby donc
ça se le sel le Saxe sur deux de
programmes donc un programme sportif et
un programme formation professionnelle
donc voilà les voilà et du scolaires
donc les portes ouvertes étaient
faites pour les joueurs issus du club et
de l'extérieur parce qu'on essaie
d'ouvrir aussi le CEL au club voisin
centre d'entraînement labellisés voilà
donc c'est un centre de formation pour
pour club amateur ce détection que vous
faites régulièrement au sein du club
tirer la Vendée on le fait tout les ans
mais je dirais que après on est en
relation avec les clubs aux alentours
pour proposer puis avec des loups on va
double licence et je veux aussi
pratiquer quoi et comment on détecte
justement les futurs potentiels par
différents thématiques proposées sur des
axes des exercices des ateliers
qui sont mis en situation donc là cette
année sur les entraînements des
catégories donc c'était les Cadets
Juniors le mercredi soir avec les
seniors juste après c'est rapidement ou
pas
bonjour de rugby ça se découvre assez
facilement alors le l'aspect technique
se voit assez facilement après le
potentiel généralement à faire des paris
sur certains sur certains profils et
puis c'est en cours de saison qu'on va
pouvoir vraiment réaliser et pouvoir
analyser les capacités des joueurs et
des joueuses en plateau notamment avec
Thierry lamendée il y a académie de
rugby qui a vu le jour depuis 2021 pour
les jeunes de 16 à 23 ans c'est
important de créer une
identité de club
des plus petits jusqu'aux plus grand
finalement ça permet également de
propose aux meilleurs éléments de rester
sur le club après c'est pas tout ça tu
as fait ce qui se fait on a quand même
beaucoup de joueurs qui partent sur le
ça français le Racing ou Massy mais je
dirais
on est entre les deux entre la structure
qui n'offre pas de complément de
d'entraînement et les clubs pro là on a
vraiment une sur quel soir de plus un
dans la semaine des axes de travail
individuels donc qui sont proposés qui
doivent vraiment améliorer puis
permettre aux jeunes de
d'être de rester chez lui quand même au
club avec l'esprit familial quand même
parce que c'est aussi l'une des marques
de fabrique de du plaisir Rugby Club
tout à fait de toute façon cette
fidélisée
un maximum et puis surtout pouvoir à
subvenir aux futurs besoins de l'équipe
du groupe senior version comme fille
justement les filles on allait en parler
dans quelques instants la section
féminine connaît un grand boom depuis
quelques mois quelques années comment
vous l'expliquez
c'est un travail qui est fait en amont
parce que on essaye
exactement c'est un travail qui fait en
amont déjà sur les millimètres et les
canettes parce qu'on a on a un collège
donc le Guillaume Apollinaire à plaisir
où il y a une section rugby donc on a un
corps professoral là-bas qui a aussi
intégré au club et qui font un grand
grand travail pour récupérer des profils
féminins et puis après on essaye aussi
de faire pas mal d'interventions dans
les écoles dans les collèges pour
recruter et puis pareil pour alimenter
dans les années futures le groupe
féminin senior actuellement sur le
l'ensemble du club une soixantaine et
vous pourriez en avoir plus parce que là
on est avec les venteurs de Vélizy donc
en association sur on entend sur les
seniors fait plus de 18 on est à peu
près presque 14 filles dans chaque club
donc mais bon c'est ça se passe bien et
puis ça se développe quoi ils entendent
c'est une solution une bonne solution
pour justement attirer plus de féminine
avoir des gros pôles de
joueuses sur sur les clubs bah oui parce
que l'objectif c'est peut-être de monter
en effectif est passé de du jeu à 10 au
jeu à 15 quoi sur les sur les filles
mais comment on fait concrètement pour
vous rejoindre si on veut une fille
derrière son poste de télévision vous
regarde en ce moment comment on fait sur
le club le site internet du club vous
avez toutes les tous les éléments et on
a parlé plusieurs projets là on sent
concrètement où vous voulez emmener le
club dans les prochaines années
l'objectif numéro un c'est de structurer
et d'avoir vraiment un club qui soit
moteur sur le bassin des Yvelines le but
c'est pas de faire de l'ombre aux autres
clubs c'est se servir de nos structures
et des compétences qu'on a au sein du
club pour pouvoir alimenter les clubs
autour aussi sur le Ceel comme je disais
tout à l'heure la création du CEL ça
permet d'avoir un objectif axé sur deux
parties donc le parti scolaire
professionnel et la partie sportive donc
on est en train d'essayer de vraiment
structurer par des partenariats avec le
club pour pour avoir une identité réelle
et un suivi qui a eu du collège
jusqu'aux études supérieures avec un
encadrement des jeunes joueurs et
joueuses voilà
quelque chose à ajouter
il le vit bien donc
on le sort on le sent très investi on le
sent très investisseurs sur le sujet
parlons pour terminer de l'équipe
seniors alors l'année prochaine on aura
de beau derbivillons on aime les appeler
comme ça il y a déjà avec Versailles
c'était déjà le cas cette saison il y
aura aussi le MLS GP et prochaine qui
fait son retour en fédéral 2 est-ce
qu'on peut parler d'objectif fédéral une
des d'ici 2027 allez voilà fiction
peut-être à la barre haute saison
une montée c'est quand même ça se
décrète pas comme ça aussi par rapport
après il faut voir aussi
des joueurs qui sont aussi des profils
un peu en fin de carrière sur certains
postes importants il faut vraiment
renouveler aussi c'est ces postes là
mais je dirais que le
l'objectif c'est de finir déjà dans les
deux premières places qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure pour avoir un
plus ou moins simplifié mais après il
faut aussi là on a appris cette année au
cours de sa prière chez nous après faut
noter qu'on a quand même été la seule
équipe même le Havre a perdu chez eux
donc
il y a quand même une vous avez gagné 28
à 27 ans je crois chez eux mais les
motifs de satisfaction c'est quand la
reprise pour la préparation estivale
c'est officiellement le cas d'après le
15 août mais les joueurs n'arrêtent pas
de la saison il y a le site des
peupliers qui était interne synthétique
ouvert pour le club donc
deux séances tous les permanence
ça c'est important parce que l'an
dernier on a vu qu'à la rentrée les
joueurs étaient avaient fait de gros
sacrifice c'était déjà arrivé
après à 100% mais
merci à tous les deux d'être passé en
plateau on va bien sûr suivre la suite
des aventures du PRC pour la saison
prochaine avec attention on espère
démonter et vous le disiez aussi un
structure plus de structuration dans le
club on de suivre ça avec attention